eight news now along with our sister
stations all across the country
are working to tackle hunger in every
community it's the super bowl of caring
and we've shared with you that our goal
is to raise enough money to feed one
million people
in need earlier this evening we caught
up with allison reese the executive
director
of super bowl of caring to find out how
she's inspiring viewers to help us reach
that goal this year
the inspiring piece is that in 2021
there's going to be a need for
over 14 billion meals to feed hungry
people
and because of that it's going to take
every single one of us
to help make that need
diminish think about it this way if
everybody
watching that big game uh that comes up
here in february
just gave one jar of peanut butter that
would be over a hundred million jars of
peanut butter
each one of those jars will create 15
meals
that would be 1.5 billion meals but
that's only one-tenth
of what the need is for 2021. that
really puts it in perspective
it really does alison can you explain
also to our viewers how your non-profit
acts more like a catalyst
for the food banks across the country
absolutely so super bowl of caring was
created
as a catalyst more like a movement
we have groups across the country
thousands of them each year
that participate in a food drive or
collect donations and they donated
100 locally whatever they do they decide
who's going to benefit
and then they make sure that those local
food charities
have what they need we've created a new
tackle hunger map
because right now none of us can go
volunteer or
really it's difficult to do a food drive
so the idea of the tackle hunger map
is that you can go to this place you can
see local food charities
you can help them right now through cash
donations that go
directly to those charities but in
addition to that
you know where those local charities are
and you can help them
because they all need a support network
and that's what our grassroots
effort has always been about is creating
that support network for food charities
you can find out more about this effort
of course on our website
eightnewsnow.com and we
certainly hope you can support our local
food banks with us on new year's eve